what is amused i mean i was josh zafty's
news when he wrote on kajal right i was
josh zafty's muse when he wrote on kajal
right i legitimate fans and young cam
yup celebs are loving the latest viral
tick tock trend featuring uncut gem star
julia fox
okay so i'm betting on the celtics
parlay three-way
money i don't know plus tip
it all started when the actress appeared
on the call her daddy podcast earlier
this month and said this i mean i was
josh safty's muse when he wrote on kajal
right do you know what i mean like
things like that the internet took
notice and can't get enough of it with
fans and celebs doing the trend all over
tik tok like ashley simpson and her pal
inanna sarkis everyone's like would you
consider yourself yay's muse
yeah a little maybe what is amused i
mean i was josh safty's news when he
wrote on kajal right and former real
housewives star bethenny frankel got in
on it too with some help from daughter
brynn what is a muse i mean i was josh
safty's news when he wrote on kajal
right marvel star clark gregg also
recruited his daughter everyone's like
would you consider yourself yay's muse
yeah a little maybe what is a muse i
mean i was josh zafti's muse when he
wrote on kajal right and bachelor alum
wells adams just really went for it i
would jack has been young
so how does julia feel about going viral
the 32 year old reacted on instagram
explaining in a comment omg i was stoned
leave me alone along with three laughing
emojis proving girl can take a joke it
was really surreal surreal is probably a
good word to describe julia's past
couple months which includes briefly
dating kanye west i call him my
boyfriend and he calls me his girlfriend
but the rapper is her boyfriend no more
earlier this week a source told e.t the
two are no longer together after dating
a little over a month you kind of like
connect the dots the breakup comes amid
the grammy winner's public attempts to
win back his estranged wife kim
kardashian on social media and on stage
[Music]
you just gotta roll with it
interestingly yay never stopped publicly
pining for his former flame while dating
julia which she addressed head on i'm
sure there's still some sort of residual
feelings and it's like it's normal it's
human you know but
i also like
know that he's with me now so
and that's all that matters despite the
split our source insists that connie and
julia remain good friends and
collaborators and it seems now the
actress is putting full focus on her
family spending quality time with her
one-year-old son
[Music]
julia is also literally moving forward
from her breakup
that's the model strutting her stuff on
the runway at the laquan smith show
during new york fashion week serving
looks in a black cutout dress
[Music]